le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
on dénombre plus de 110000 illettrés à
la réunion une situation inacceptable
contre laquelle le département veut
lutter pour encourager le développement
de la lecture et de l'écriture
la collectivité a créé l'opération
premières pages chaque année un livret
distribué dans les familles pour toute
nouvelle naissance ou adoption
[Musique]
paquet poule vivent en liberté et tous
les matins c'est pareil
ricco pour mon petit rico viens par ici
si du haut de ses dix mois yunnan ne
comprend pas encore toute l'histoire
pour magali son assistante maternelle
les livres restent un outil pédagogique
comme il ya des jolies couleurs il ya
une belle histoire on peut attirer son
attention déjà ils m'aiment bien le
cocher pas tellement de par la lecture
aussi d'accord t'as fait une activité à
part entière dans dans l'éducation de
l'enfant le peintre l'histoire du coq
ricco a justement été créé pour
sensibiliser les petits à la lecture à
la distribution de livres à la maison du
département pour les enfants nés en 2007
tous les ans le département organise
l'opération premières pages le principe
offrir un livre aux familles de nouveau
né à travers cette opération
nous voulons aussi lutter contre le
phénomène catastrophique de
l'illettrisme à la réunion cent dix neuf
mille situation d'illettrisme recensés
c'est trop et nous voulons par cette
action sensibiliser les familles
permettre aux jeunes enfants d'aborder
la lecture de façon ludique agréable lui
permettre d'acquérir les bases pour
pouvoir grandir et être à l'aise dans la
vie et pour cette septième édition
la collectivité a mis en place un
concours pour les auteurs réunionnais ma
part sollicité directement les éditeurs
mais on a sollicité les auteurs et les
illustrateurs pour la première fois et
nous avons eu 112 propositions de livres
[Musique]
ça va parmi ces propositions
c'est le monde imaginaire de deux soeurs
qui a séduit le jury
alors j'ai ressorti à l'annonce du
concours lancé par le département
lisa et muriel ont plongé dans
l'aventuré entier vu je me suis dit mais
c'est quelque chose pour nous c'est sûr
c'est évident d'autant plus que qu'elle
et moi on avait déjà pour projet de
travailler ensemble et donc à sa tombe
et ça tombait bien parce que toutes les
conditions au final était réuni moi j'ai
rapidement écrit quelques lignes
lorsqu'on s'est décidé à participer à ce
concours
le but c'était vraiment décrire quelque
chose assez vite pour que ma soeur et le
temps de l'illustré rico ouais il se
cache alors on va s'amuser à les
chercher trouver alors j'avais déjà
imaginé des personnages pour un album ça
ne s'est pas fait mais ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai fait j'ai j'ai récupéré l'idée
du personnage qui existait déjà dans
premier dans mon premier livre et j'ai
essayé d'imaginer plus petit ce héros
série coco un petit coq un peu bougon
est assez téméraire on a envie de le
découvrir savoir qu'est ce qui fait qu
est-ce qui va faire est ce que on sent
bien que c'est un petit malin petit
farceur
le jeune coq a pris forme sous les
traits de crayon de muriel assez vite
ans j'avais eu l'idée de ce petit corps
qu'avec sa petite sa petite crête ta
petite crête n'a commencé à travailler
sur les pages denses que j'ai déposé mes
décors ensuite les premières
illustrations sont sortis en couleurs
fait à la tablette graphique sur un
ordinateur une basse-cour bien ancrée
dans la culture réunionnaise et ses
références
les parents de ce petit de ce petit coq
qui s'appelle maintenant lundi papa l'a
fait il ya aussi un peu de voisins se
sont bavards
poussés on a aussi les fanas de kiffer
le corps voilà
mary coco n'est pas d'accord non non et
non
il lève la tête soulève sa queue et pas
de patates y adeux patata pour les deux
soeurs c'est une grande fierté d'être
les lauréates de l'année ça a été à un
moment un moment magique à vivre parce
que c'est à travers nos moore et nos
dessins au final que ces petits jeux de
2016 vont découvrir un bel ouvrage opus
qui a été écrit par deux amoureux
d'honneur et liu a été vraiment unis une
histoire écrite par une famille pour les
familles réunionnaises l'opération
premières pages a pour but de promouvoir
la lecture et l'écriture dès le plus
jeune âge un moyen de lutter contre
l'illettrisme qui touche cent dix neuf
mille personnes sur notre île tous les
ans lors de cette opération
un cadeau de naissance est offert aux
familles accueillant à nouveau né un
livre pour les enfants et un guide de
lecture pour les parents pour plus de
renseignements vous pouvez consulter le
site du département au www.cgi.com
4 point fr
[Musique]